the establishment left has just dropped
entirely so the Democratic Party
whatever that is abandoned the
working-class generation okay let's get
straight into the question is that all
right
oh yeah okay so Peter you can mute your
mic if you don't mind okay
okay so what I wanted to know is the
first I wanted to define the left and
essentially the way that I'm going to do
that is by asking you what are the
traits in the left the left political
left in the past century that have
changed and what's remained the same as
far as you can tell
well of course the left has moved
consistently to new issues that weren't
even noticed before so if you go back a
century well there were elements of the
left that controls a feminist it's
nothing like the dominant the dominant
element in lift politics that exists
today you go back 20 years ago it's very
little concern about the environment now
on the Left recognizes that it's an
existential problem the on the other
hand and said there many cases in which
there's been progress in understanding
and dedicated work there are other cases
in which there's regression so go back
not very far a couple of decades a
Labour Organisation was a major issue
for the left it was recognized
understood that the driving force in any
social and political economic change
it's going to be an organized working
class that's been well depends which
call the left but the establishment left
has just dropped it entirely so the
Democratic Party whatever that is
abandoned the working-class generation
ago hand it over their class enemy
activists on the Left have become
engaged justifiably with issues that are
sometimes called identity politics those
are real issues have to be dealt with
but class issues have been subordinated
of marginalized and they're very real
that's a deficiency that has to be
overcome all of these things interact
when people talk about intersectionality
it's right but it's in more of a slogan
and a an actual achievement so I think
if you look at course
the board there's progress regression
what is your opinion on identity
politics the issues are significant they
have to they enter they cannot each type
of identity politics cannot dominate a a
commitment of an organized lift that
hopes to achieve things they have to
interact be mutually supportive and they
have to crucially bring in the class
issues that have been subordinated
actually the most active extreme form of
identity politics is white nationalism
something I'm trying to determine with
my research is when does the left to go
too far and when does the right to go
too far politically speaking and I
wanted to know what your opinion is on
that just to pick the issues I mean the
right at this point is simply suicidal
it's not a question of going too far the
right is committed to destruction of
organized human society is that an
extreme statement maybe but it's correct
I'll just take a look at the Republican
Party what is the Republican Party
committed to it's committed to
destroying human life and not in the
long term the Paris agreements a couple
of years ago they weren't fabulous but
they were something at least their
original effort intent was to create a
treaty in which there would be
verifiable commitments to some measures
to avert the huge threat of global
warming couldn't get a treaty it had to
be a voluntary agreement why Republican
senators wouldn't accept it I think the
Republican primary in 2016
every single candidate without exception
either denied that global warming is
taking place or L said maybe it is but
we don't care we're gonna John Kasich it
was throwing of Ohio who's considered
the real moderate of the group said yeah
we recognize that global warming is
taking place in it's serious but we
intricate in Ohio are going to use our
cold and we're not more apologize for it
that's the moderate Republican then you
go over to the White House yes total
maniacs and people who say we don't care
I said we'll destroy the world but we'll
have profit tomorrow and are leading the
way towards destruction consciously
aware of what they're doing the most
secret about easy to demonstrate no far
too late is this on
there's no words for and what am i one
question what about the left when does
the left go too far it's not a matter of
going too far as a matter of making
tactical decisions that are incorrect
you have to if you may there's a it may
be that some of the goals go debatable
talk about that but insofar as there are
the kinds of goals that say we think we
can support you have to ask whether the
tactics that are used or well designed
to meet those goals or else undermine
the goals so let's take concrete cases
as you know I was very active in the
anti-war movement resistance movement
during the nineteen sixties contact with
Vietnamese the Vietnamese were appalled
but some of the tactics that were being
used
I remember meetings with Vietnamese
would plead with American activists not
to do things like what the withum men
are doing
I'm the Weathermen a lot of young people
who many of them I knew that were
perfectly sincere they thought that the
way to end the war is to smash up the
windows on Main Street it's not the way
to end the war and that was the way to
enrage construction workers and others
so they'd be more aware than they were
before the Vietnamese that didn't care
or whether Americans felt good they
cared whether they could survive so what
they advocated were measures so mild
that a lot of the war movement were just
laughing but that's the kind of choice
that has to be made all the time and get
PA examples today so going too far I
think we we should rephrase that as
taking tactics that are going to
undermine the perhaps the perhaps the
German in just goals that you say you're
advocating on the discussion of the left
and the right in terms of their
differences in their similarities
oftentimes the
they're characterized as being
pro-government and the rightest
characterized as I'd be pro corporation
and you've written about the revolving
door between the two between regulators
and the regulated in your book like
manufacturing consent
now does this blur the line of what it
means to be a left winger and a right
winger do the left and the right still
exist
did they have urgent I mean let's take
being proud or any government that's not
a a general position of the left
that's a tactical choice in particular
circumstances so when you have a state
like the United States that's largely
dominated by private tyrannies with very
little of public voice in that
particular circumstance the option
available to you to overcome this is
governmental action which at least to
some extent is responsive to public
opinion in other circumstances when
you're trying to construct a really
libertarian left participatory society
you might want to dissolve both
governmental structures as legitimate
Authority there's no right or left right
or wrong answer to that so for example
let's take takes a media okay the United
States is unusual it's just different
from other developed societies in many
respects at one respect is it doesn't
have public fairly as public media okay
Meteor private oh I just overwhelming is
a kind of a little tiny fringe on the
Left mother bleep on the Gulf the friend
Jim says like nothing like the BBC or
anything like that we can look at why
this happened certainly not implicit in
US history like the founders of the
conjuring the framers believed they
interpreted the First Amendment very
differently than the way we do they
thought it meant that's the government
ought to take an act
if rule in sponsoring a free and
independent Chris that's why we have the
post office for example it's early years
the post office was almost totally
devoted to providing a cheap free
basically subsidies to the Boyd variety
of journals and newspapers to encourage
varied free independent press over the
years the power of private power in the
United States which is quite unusual
managed to privatize a radio television
and more recently the Internet but
that's and yes in those circumstances it
would make sense to call for a public
voice under other circumstances you
might want to have local local based you
know worker based community-based media
and there's many other such questions
your self-described anarchist and I'd
like to know what is the difference
between your beliefs and contemporary
libertarianism well first of all woods
called libertarian in the United States
is some ultra-right advocacy as private
tyrannies nothing nothing like anything
that was libertarian traditionally but
if you're talking about less libertarian
it's you know covers quite a range but
just as the term anarchism does but
there is a kind of a core and the center
of it I think the core running through
the whole tradition with many variations
is the recognition that there are
certain structures in social political
life economic life that are that have to
justify their own legitimacy there are
coercive authoritarian there is a
hierarchy domination somebody gives you
or somebody takes them all of those
structures
have to be or none of those structures
are self-justifying they have a burden
of justification if they can't meet it
it's almost always the case that should
be dismantled I think that's the core
principle and land view is that once you
get to the basics almost every normal
person it's in this sense but that's
then you have to ask how it applies so
do you have a job somewhere well if you
have a job in a business corporation
let's say you're living in a tyranny so
extreme that no totalitarian dictator
ever dreamed of it so for example Stalin
didn't tell people look they have ten
minutes to go to the bathroom every
couple of hours you have to wear these
clothes not some other clothes if you're
not allowed to stop to talk to a friend
for a minute your your monitor say it or
an Amazon warehouse so that if you don't
pick up enough things fast I know if you
like you maybe you stopped it Bree
there's nothing you get a demerit there
was no totalitarian dictatorship like
that that's most of people's lives well
is that a legitimate structure is the
labor contract legitimate every
traditional classical liberals didn't
think so
Abraham Lincoln didn't think so the
Republican Party didn't think Republican
Party slogan in the mid 19th century
early Industrial Revolution was that
wage labor is indistinguishable from
slavery except that it's was emperor
until you become a free person well okay
that's that those ideas have been driven
out of people's heads but I don't think
they're very far below the surface they
can emerge and that would be authentic
left libertarian it just one aspect so
it seems like you overlap with regards
to free exchange of speech and ideas and
I remember a while ago you helped you
defended a Holocaust denier and I wanted
to know if you still stand by that
defending a Holocaust I mean defending
his freedom is
sure I'm in this it's just standard
classical liberalism you there's two
choices either some form of power or an
authority typically the state of other
determines what's true and punishes any
deviation from what he claims is true or
else you will of used to be expressed
that you know like in fact if you really
believe in freedom of speech the only
issues are do I allow speech that I
don't like Hitler and Stalin had nothing
against speech they like nowadays
there's this trans rights versus free
speech late and I want to know what you
think about that where do you lie on
that list of Holocaust denial for
another minute the Holocaust denial is
the norm in Western society so but for
just take an example a couple of years
ago an article appeared in The New York
Review the major journal full of lift
liberalism in which the author good
decent left liberals was reviewing a
book by a major American historian who
said that he said in his review he was
struck it was interested to learn that
when the early explorers came to the
Western Hemisphere there were only about
a million people from the tropical
forests to the frozen north he was off
by about 60 or 70 million who were wiped
out said Holocaust and did anybody say
he should be imprisoned I did anybody
even notice I mean these things happen
all the time it's a particular form that
we don't like that somebody doesn't like
that's considered it has to be
suppressed and that's worth keeping in
mind when you talk about all I gots
denial so it seems like
you have some similarities with Jordan
Peterson on this issue and I know that
you haven't talked too much about Jordan
Peterson and I wanted to know if you had
any disagreements with what he says
frankly I just love tension but if you
want to know about Jordan Peters and I
think the best thing I can refer you to
is a article boy Nathan Robin Robinson
very sharp acute critic and his journal
current affairs it's called something
like the intellectual we deserve or
something like that I think that that's
basically my answers other than that I
don't pay anything I mean there's some
issues and which I probably agree with
Hitler no doesn't mean much on that
subject I think it's Aristotle right who
says that people get the governments
they deserve is this kind of the light
of Aristotle said that people get the
governments they deserve is this kind of
what you're implying but for
intellectual no I don't think people get
the government they deserve they get the
government at power systems imposed
that's quite different on the systems of
power you had mentioned in manufacturing
consent the idea of the principle of
bureaucratic affinity the idea that
large-scale bureaucracies will ally with
other large guild bureaucracies to sort
of maintain the status quo and to hate
each other and that when a company like
when a media company for example tries
true journalism these large
bureaucracies be either the government
or corporations will give the media
company flak and sort of cease to work
with them my question for you
question for you is just the principle
of bureaucratic affinity apply to
educational institutions like large
universities to a varying extent but
depends on the university it depends on
the time and the era you know there's in
our current situation current
circumstances with all their flaws that
universities are one of the last
mansions bastions of the relative
freedom of expression of research even
of worker self-government to a certain
extent faculty at a university has a
degree of control over their working
lives which is very rare in the existing
socio-political system so I don't think
you can answer a simple yes-or-no by
comparative standards they're really
free they have flaws so for example if
you take a look at the American
University System LaBella just a few
years ago you couldn't find a Marxist
professor anywhere in any other country
in the world they'd be all over the
place out here I asked what do you
attribute that to in your in past
comments you had mentioned how academics
maintain a sort of status quo as opposed
to being the sort of radicals that they
display themselves as do you find that
still true or do you find that academics
are changing
well okay and there's a kind of an ebb
and flow I think it's less true than it
was fifty or sixty years ago but it's
more true than it oughta be and it's not
just academics its intellectuals
generally that look over the whole
history of intellectuals for a couple of
thousand years in fact and you find that
overwhelmingly have a tentative support
power assistance there are a few who
don't want and they usually treated
pretty harshly in fact just take the the
term intellectual in its modern sense
was first used at the time of the
Dreyfus trial in France late nineteenth
century most of the intellectuals the
prestigious intellectuals the ones of
the you know French Academy and so on
bitterly condemned the Dreyfus or how
dare are these writers and artists
questioned the majesty of our Army
States and so on there were a few like
Emile Zola a couple of others who stood
up against it they were persecuted and
we may honor them today but not at the
time ambles all had to flee France
that's the record in one form or another
all through history
so the fact shortly after after this
first world war came alone it was very
dramatic to see what happened to the
intellectual classes a dream this is
including the left during the first
world war in every single country
Germany France England the United States
the intellectuals lined up almost a
hundred percent and passionate support
of their own country the ones who didn't
many of them ended up in jail that
Bertrand Russell Rosa Luxemburg Eugene
Debs that's the pattern
we're back we're back computer do you
want to repeat the question
super quick there's my wife hi thank you
thank you hello professor Noam Chomsky's
wife okay
the question in some rooms in
manufacturing consent you teach us that
big media is allied with the government
corporate elites and as a result the
framework of big medias discussion fits
comfortably in a propaganda model an
acceptable framework on how to analyze
problems and talk about issues well if
if academia itself is allied with
government and corporate elites then
wouldn't they also fit a propaganda
model and if not what makes them so
unique for one thing there's several
things that are to some extent it's true
but notice that the relation of media to
say corporate elites is very different
from the relation of universities to
corporate elites
in the case of media it's just that's
what they are the media are major
corporations parts of bigger
corporations flow in and out of
government very heavily subject to
government to edicts and so on the
universities have the same influences
but much less the relation of a
university to corporations is kind of
get a grant
you know I will I get a will to be a
donor will be willing to that's very
different from being a part of the
corporate system which already allows a
little flexibility also there is we
should not underestimate the fact that
there is a sense of professionalism and
intellectual responsibility that's true
in the media too there are serious
journalists who many of them understand
the system very well they didn't have to
hear it from us
to try to find ways to combat it and it
happens now in the media they tend to be
marginalized and eliminated you know
sent to the police desk you're not
really ready for big guy work when it's
risen and that kind of thing happens in
the universe is - but probably to a
slightly lesser extent and it depends
also on the field so many fields in the
university are almost totally free from
outside pressures physics department
forces some people have suggested that
they should that we should remove
universities but and this is Raymond
Norton Peterson for example said suggest
students don't go to universities
anymore because of the bias because of
the unitary point of views and this is
reminiscent of anarchists ivanovitch's
desire to eliminate listen to what
jordan Peterson is saying he's saying
universities are dominated by the lifts
for him the lift is anybody - the lift
is Attila the Hun in fact universities
are dominated by the right he's so far
on the right that that looks like the
left in but does it make sense to tell
students not to go to universities it's
crazy
it's one of the places where you can
lots of things wrong but there are
resources and opportunities that simply
don't exist anywhere else so you can't
there are opportunities to become free
independent creative individuals working
with others they just don't have
elsewhere sorry I miss sorry I misspoke
I didn't mean that to suggest that he
suggested to eliminate the universities
I mean I'm more trying to convey the
decentralization of universities so for
example an online school there's a lot
omission in online school your peers one
of the big parts of education is the
students you're with that those kinds of
interactions are gone online and they're
very important for educating oneself
anybody who's been in a
through a school or university situation
knows how you can learn more from
interaction with your peers than from
sitting in on a lecture even interaction
with the faculty so it's one thing to
sit in a lecture class or watch a
television screen and it's another thing
to be in an actual class where you're
interacting with other students and with
the faculty so yes there are good things
I mean I think it's good to try to
extend the resources of a university
elsewhere
but there's nothing to replace the
direct at face to face interaction not
just when you're in class but when
you're when you're doing something else
from here I'm sitting in a McDonald's
and having a hamburger looking friends
talking what are your thoughts on the
Christian anarchists Yvonne it'll äj--
and his rise in popularity among social
activists yeah an anarchist who believed
in d.school in society is popular work
and sort of understand some of the
motivation for it but the d.school in
society is taking away from people some
of their major opportunities for
individual growth and social interaction
and even even general activism I mean
it's not just pure accident that over
the years student activism has been one
at the forefront of many of the most
important social movements partly it's
just because young people are period of
their life when they're relatively free
but it's also the fact that they're
together they can talk with one another
they can interact that's something's
pretty much missing an atomized
capitalist society then I'm running into
a little bit of a confusion here on the
one hand the history of intellectuals in
academia sort of lines up with the
status quo in the sense of we were
talking about Nazism things before but
on the other hand they're on
forefront of social change how are these
views compatible their participants are
in the forefront of social change the
mainstream may be status quo and
conservative which it is take a look at
student activism it's usually opposed by
the administration and most of the
faculty but nevertheless it takes place
because this is a relatively free
institution which means that there are
opportunities to break out of the
doctrinaire sister system of attempted
Ridge rotation you know we're not living
in totalitarian dictatorships where if
you say the wrong thing you get sent to
the to the concentration camp we're
living in societies with a relative
degree of freedom often infringed by
authoritarian structures but they don't
have the kind of force they do if the SS
troops are standing behind you we
shouldn't compare ourselves with that in
that case what is an anarcho-syndicalist
s-- take on education on what it should
look like and what needs to change from
how it is now to how it should be
actually the anarchist movement not just
an affair syndicalists we're in the
forefront of developing progressive
education systems so for example in
Spain where the 1936 revolution was the
leading of the most successful so for
example of an anarchist revolution I was
preceded by the decades of educational
efforts and villages and towns
everywhere
trying to create a free Liberatore
environment in which students could find
their own ways their creativity would be
sponsored they would work jointly with
one another very similar to progressive
education tendencies John Dewey's those
which I had benefit from as a trial
effect familiar with taught that way as
well
so yes anarchist education
progessive that there's also people like
pilot ferry or he that should be an
interactive process where the teachers
learning from the students not just
students having freedom that's what I
think that's the kind of direction that
education should take the course that
should follow and does in the better
places do you feel that if education is
too centralized these alternative
platforms will be sidelined neglected in
the public sphere or for example in
universities that student participation
would get minimalized I don't think
there's a simple answer you could have a
public education system which Foster's
individual creativity the freedom
student initiative and so on you could
have a scattered system of charter
schools which are business run and we
can pose discipline it depends on the
educational program not whether it's
central depends okay I have a question
that either you would think it's our
completely polar opposite or core that
they completely overlap what were you
thinking during your interview your
conversation with Foucault and what were
you thinking during your conversation
with Ali G with I didn't hear the first
one with Foucault and with Ali G well it
was quite different in the case of Ali G
there had been a I was not particularly
interested in the interview but the I
think was the BBC whoever was behind it
gave me a big song and dance about how
this might be very sheer senator I
finally agreed soon as he walked in I
realized this is joke tried to be polite
but I had a hard time but I didn't take
it seriously no you mean to say you
realized that it was a joke or you felt
like the whole interview was a joke and
you thought he was for real the whole
thing was obviously some kind of
effort at comedy which I didn't want to
be part of and ice perfectly I mean was
on the tip of my tongue saying look this
is enough let's terminate it but being
polite I went along with it for a while
because it's quite different actually we
had bent Foucault and I had spent a
large part of the day together the
interview was a debate wasn't evening I
was just walking around the Dutch
countryside
partly because we wanted to have a
chance to talk but partly to see if we
could get by with him - looking French
and be talking English would we be able
to understand each other especially we
had the translator we finally figured we
could carry it off I don't know much
French there's no much English but it
worked and the debate was about issues
that are fairly serious issues so
nothing we disagreed about a lot of
things I was appalled by something
pretty serious but it was within the
domain of rational discourse okay I know
you're a busy oh sorry I know you're a
busy person I only have two more
questions and they're super quick one is
what are your thoughts on post-modernism
what do you agree with and what do you
disagree with well for about couple of
decades I've had a very simple question
that I've been posing to my postmodern
friends can you find something in
post-modernism which is not either a
triviality cloaked in policy levels or
is false and nobody's inserted yet so
that's federal incident okay and then my
last question was you're extremely
prolific you've written I think over a
hundred books at least on politics and
then many more in other subjects how do
you structure your day what's your
productivity look like your routine
right now since my wife and I moved to
Arizona I'm not living in Cambridge
anymore my routine is to get up early in
the morning take our dogs out play with
them for a while
read the newspaper start looking at the
huge quantity of email would piled up if
I get rid of that but the word them
serious things topic did you clean your
room just get it
I said out but did you clean your room
clean join Peterson reference there's
very little oxygen in the room mostly
books and papers much clean thank you so
much professor and thank you what's your
wife's name Valeria valaria hi hi thank
you so much thank you yeah I'll send you
a link to this interview as well give
you a copy of the interview sure thank
you I appreciate it have a great day go
back to playing with your dogs and make
sure you clean up your room because I
think that's the most important I think
that's more important than writing books